It says, "Brother from Sheffield calling
out Muang for watering down the
religion." Okay, so the first one was
what? The first one was what? Man from
Sheffield gets mad at Mui men for making
a joke. Bro, that's your friend. That
means you know he was going to be there.
There's another guy recording this 100%.
It's been meditated. And then you are
making a statement. Man from Sheffield
gets mad at Muy men for making a joke.
You know that's not true. Why did you
make that caption? Why do you actually
That's a lie. That is a lie.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, Masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count brothers and
sisters and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
£500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1,10,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Asalamaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well in. So as you
guys know I done a video about mu man
yesterday being confronted by a brother.
He's our brother. He's he's a Muslim.
Alhamdulillah. You know Mu man is our
brother. He's a Muslim. But I found some
stuff really troubling because the
brother who confronted Mu without any
reason by the way without any reason not
knowledge base no wisdom based no adak
based. There was no basis to it. He made
a video coming out. But before that, I'm
starting to sense by looking at his
friends post on Instagram that this is
some kind of a marketing strategy or
this was something that was actually uh
coordinated and planned, premeditated.
Why? You're going to see for yourself
now. We're going to go to the videos,
but this brother is posting these videos
which is lies. It is a lie. And the
prophetam said the believer is anything
but a liar. On one of your posts, you
said what? Oh uh that um mufty men um
couldn't take a joke or something like
that or something joke was made. It had
nothing to do with the joke. Why are you
lying? Look one of the uh the prophetam
said a person will be called a liar and
they asked him how he said they will say
say a lie. There will be people fire
that that lie will spread so far.
Brother your videos on Instagram have
got hundreds of thousands of views and
they are a statement that is a lie
that's been spread worldwide. And the
prophetam spoke about this that the lie
will be spread so far and wide. Why
would you risk your hereafter over
something like less and I'm not seeing
because from we judge from a parent like
said we used to judge from now we judge
from a parent from what it seems bro is
you're putting a video a video video and
then you put a marketing thing. I want
to watch you look let's before we come
to the statement of this brother. Yeah.
Check this out for yourself guys on the
screen. So I'm going to have this full
screen inshallah and you guys can watch
it for yourself. Here's this is account.
Okay, let's go into inshallah. Yeah, so
as you can see this is account he does
something pertaining to um the green
pill project. I don't know what the
green pill project is. Yeah. Okay.
So that's the first one. Then it says
brother from Sheffield calling out Mang
for watering down the religion. Okay. So
the first one was what? The first one
was what? Man from Sheffield gets mad at
Mui Mang for making a joke. Bro, that's
your friend. That means you know he was
going to be there. There's another guy
recording this 100% it's premeditated
and then you are making a statement man
from Sheffield gets mad at Muy men for
making a joke. You know that's not true.
Why did you make that caption? Why do
you actually That's a lie. That is a
lie. Let's carry on. And then he makes
another brother from call me for
watering down the religion. Brother, you
just contradicted yourself. And Allah
subhanaa, let me tell you something. The
prophetam said, "If anyone looks for the
fault of his brother, Allah will make
his fault found in his own house,
brother." Subhan Allah. Just think about
this. You were looking for the fault of
m and you contradicted yourself in your
very post that was you was doing in your
house. If this is not the hadith coming
to reality, tell me what it is. Because
on one post you're saying it's because
of a joke that was made. In this next
post you're saying brother from sheff
calls out mang for watering down the
religion brother. If I come and say one
statement another post and another post
you say that's a contradiction. Is it
this or is it that? Look how Allah
subhana exposed. This is why I say if
you guys hunt for other people's
mistakes wall Allah will humiliate you.
Wallah if you have a disease of your
heart you're looking for people's
mistake. How can I cash them out? Oh you
know I need content. I'm a content
maker. Yeah, if I have this disease
where I'm like, "Ah, bro, I need some
content today. How can I catch someone
out? Oh, let me look for something. Oh,
content is not good. Let me w That's a
disease of the heart. May Allah subh
protect us." So, your second video was
what? Totally opposing what you said,
which the first one was a lie. Let's
carry on. Let's And I'm going to go to
the video of this other brother. Yeah.
Okay. Then the other one is what? Man
from Sheff.
Okay. That's the one we've already uh if
I'm not mistaken already mentioned and
this is where he's getting escorted.
Yeah. Okay. Then afterwards, brothers
and sisters, we go, "Look, now he's
talking about introducing the green
pill."
Bro, you're coordinating this, bro. You
are basically saying, first post a lie.
Second post contradicts me, contradicts
the first thing that I said. The third
one is about introducing the green bill.
And what does it say? Let's read it for
ourselves. Uh, link in the look look in
the bio. Is this something that
it says what UK's Muslims
me self-development project? This
community is your turning point. Stop
feeling stuck, unfilled or disrespected.
Everything you need to grow in your
dean. And by the way, can we find out?
Is this paid? Is it paid? Can we find
out please?
>> Is it paid? Is it a paid thing that that
they subscribe to pay?
>> Oh, yes it is. There's a website he's
got. It's called www.school.com.
>> Yeah. He's charging to join $3 a month.
got 19 members and it's a
>> and and and and you're charging. Look,
look, there's nothing wrong. If you're
offering something to the um that
benefits, there's nothing wrong with
that. But are you telling me this was a
coincidence? And now you're introducing
look why you should join. Check this
out. Why you should join? Join the green
pill project. Okay. Subhan Allah. Look,
Quran and Sunnah. Yeah. Quran and
Sunnah. Yes. Okay. Join us. So
basically, bro, in a nutshell, this is a
marketing strategy for you, bro. This is
a marketing strategy. You've done this
come out with this facade that Muf is
misguided by making post about lies. Now
I'm going to get straight into the
actual video of his friend who was the
guy who confronted Mu. Let's see what
his justification was. Yeah. In the
beginning of this video is that is that
guy who owns this green pill uh thing.
Okay. And let me tell you something.
He's probably happy. He's thinking, you
know, alhamdulillah I was talking about
it. Oh, it's more exposure to me. Well,
let me tell you something. If your
intention is this, and by the way, I
don't care. I live to Allahh. If you are
happy that you are getting any press
even if it's bad press and you think
your wrist is going to come like that
wall I'm telling you I will mention it
the green pill the green pill are you
happy green peel yes green peel green
peel green pill wow amazing are you
happy is this why you did all of this
are you happy is it good yeah you got
marketing wah shame on you man is this
how you get your risk is this how you
have and you want to come and talk about
mink misguiding brother you're
misguiding yourself let's carry on
>> was slandered all over the internet was
mocked by mu mink and was disrespected
by the mischief
>> one second We all watched the video.
Where did Muf mock him, bro? Bro, how
are you lying, bro? We watched the
video. Wait, Allah's witness. I am no
like I'm not a fanboy of Mu with all
Jews respect. I'm not here. I'm just
saying, bro, what you're saying is not
true. Where did Muy men mock him? Bro, I
played the full video on my video. You
can see I have the full video from the
masid. Where did Muy men mock him?
Where? He did the opposite. Don't lie.
Fear Allah. Wallah. Fear Allah. Let's
carry on.
>> All because he wanted to forbid the
evil. Not only this, he had the police
phoned on him like he's a criminal by
the masid.
>> By the way, the masid calling the police
on him was absolutely wrong. There was
no need to call the police. No need. I'm
so sorry. With all due respect to the
masid, I understand they could have
escorted him. But to call the police was
not needed. It's another believer. It's
not needed actually. And that's a
mistake that could happen in the masid.
May Allah forgive them. Okay. And now
this brother saying, "Why?" Cuz he
wanted to enjoy the good for evil. Yaki,
how old are you, bro? My brother, how
old are you, man? What do you mean by
enjoying the good? What are you talking
about? What are you talking about, bro?
What do you mean? Do you even know the
principles of enjoying good and evil,
bro? Huh? Go over read. What is enjoying
good and evil? Do you know
Ajib brothers? What lie a man? Young
ignorant people.
>> And he was banned from going back to
this mission. The brother sent me this
video because he doesn't have social
media. Let's look at his side of things
and then make your judgment. Due to Tik
Tok only allowing 3 minutes for the
video, I'll be posting the full thing on
the YouTube. The YouTube is in the
comments. Uh
>> firstly, Instagram does not stop a copy
at 3 minutes. That's not true. Again,
that's not true. Anyway, that could be
you did not know. Okay, let's carry on.
Um I'm sure many of you have seen the
video that has gone viral uh yesterday
um or have heard about the situation
that happened yesterday in the MUI talk
um in
um and before you judge me and my
actions uh you must first hear my side
and then whatever picture that you want
to paint whatever conclusion you want to
uh paint after that then feel free to do
so.
First of all, before I address uh my
points, I would like to first make you
understand those that don't understand
this main point. And that is that our
religion today is being watered down.
And a lot of us do not understand the
religion the way it should be
understood.
>> Brother, brother, just in my first
reaction for this. Yeah. Wai, you seem
like a
How can I explain? W I'm looking at you
and I would not wa I'll be honest with
you. If I listened to your video and
didn't see what he did in the match, I
would never ever think someone like you
softspoken, calm spoken, you look
well-mannered. Well, I'll be honest with
you, I am absolutely shocked that that's
you. That can that cannot be you, bro.
Unless you have a split personality,
this show up, bro. Bro, you seem very
well spoken. You seem like you have good
manners, good etiquets, your voices,
your pitches come, you don't seem like
like me, I'm I'm a bit ragggo, you get
I'm like, you know, people can come and
say, you know, okay, if Ali done that,
yeah, maybe. But, bro, I don't expect
that from you. And now you're also
saying that people are talking without
knowledge. Aki wall with all due respect
this is you're talking about yourself.
With all due respect bro I want to ask
you a question. On what basis are you
saying accusing who's watering down
what? Where's your evidences bro? And
not only that there are ethicists and
adab. There's books on manners written.
Yes. Read readab from imari basic adab
and manners bro. In even if you're going
to correct someone how you go about it.
Let's carry on.
>> And understand Islam the way it should
be understood and the way that the
companions
understood Islam.
>> Okay. What makes you think you have
understood that correctly? You you have
to tell me. You have to bring me
evidence. You have understood it
correctly and the man or anyone else who
hasn't. Aki, how old are you? You look,
bro. You look 22 or 23 years old, bro.
You're a young man. Aki, you you you've
gone to a masid. You've disturbed it. No
manners on what ba theology bidder
on what basis do you think what you did
was right please tell me you you can't
just come and haphazardly like make
stuff up brother bring evidence yes
bring evidence to what you what you've
done on what basis
>> and the way that they understood it was
by uh
enjoining in good and forgetting evil
and Allahh says in the Quran
you are the greatest people that was
sent to mankind and the greatest um why
you were enjoying and good and you evil.
>> Okay. Yes, that's correct. But like like
like they said abd
who went to Yeah. And I'm not saying
this brothers that I he said the
statement you say is true but the
application is battle. What you're
saying is you caught in the Quran my
brother please brothers and sisters
don't fall for this Quran vers he
recite. Look look look you're talking
about enjoying with good and evil. Okay
I am someone in the front lines who try
to do that in all angles advising our
brothers and sisters and I get attacked
left right saying brother I called haram
police. I'm called the spy. I'm called
this everything. Why? Because I try to
enjoy to the best of my ability and
knowing my lane. I don't go out of my
lane. I try to stick to my lane. Okay. Y
it says when the prophetam said if you
see evil stop it with your hand. If you
can't stop with your hand stop it with
your tongue. If you can't stop with your
tongue then hit it in your heart. Even
Tamia says that when it comes to with
your hand he says this is talking about
the the ruler if he has the ability.
Now you read that and go yeah stop with
the hand. Okay. What's this talking
about? Now I'm not saying this always
applies to the ruler. But what I'm
saying is brother you don't understand.
We know the dean cause for that and we
are the best um because of that. But you
are quoting an ayah reciting in Arabic.
Okay. The Quran. How does that prove
your point? How does that prove the
point that what you've done was correct?
And Allahhana wa tala when talking about
when talking about the children of
Allahh he said the curse was Allah's
curse was upon them. Why? Because they
did not forbid the evil. And he mentions
the second verse after that. He says
vile is what they used to do.
That thing of not forbiddenly evil is
evil in Allah's eyes.
And the reason why I say this is because
the likes of Mlink and the likes of the
D today is that they enjoy the good and
they do not for the evil. And the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
himself when addressing and of
did he just tell them command them to
worship Allah? that Allahh command just
to worship Allah for Qurish believed in
Allahhana
Allahh says this and he explains he
explains to us
if you was to ask the Qur the ones that
worship the idols who created the
heavens and earth they will say Allah
and Allahh also mentions that if you was
to ask them who is your provider who's
your sustainer they will say Allah so
why is it that if they believed in this
why did they worship idols what was the
excuse Okay, we understand that. But I'm
I'm I'm just trying to understand,
brother. You're you you've made a video.
And by the way, this is the only video
I've seen. I don't know if there's a
full version. I can't find it. It's been
taken down. Why is your point, bro? I
don't understand. You confronted Mu,
shouted him down, which against the
dean. Like, I'll be honest with you.
Islamic principles, etiquette, adabl,
all of that. Well, the Muslims are
listening. Subhan Allah. And let me tell
you something. Let me tell you
something. I think if I'm mistaken, it
was Abdas. was giving a speech, a
talkbas
and the time for salah came and it was
going. One of the men stood up and said,
"Oh,
he said the salah time." And he
acknowledged and he said, "Do you think
I don't know?" He had evidences. He had
evidences of why he delayed or
something. I don't know what it was
specifically. Yeah. The point is what
somebody will look and go, "Oh, this
guy's abd misguided. Subhan Allah. Time
is coming. It's nearly going, etc.,
etc." Brother, there is evidences from
the Quran that you don't know. You are
talking about the mushri. They believe
in Allah. Yes. Allah says in the Quran.
If you was to ask them who's the one
who's the one who created they say Allah
but they're still mushri. What's that
got to do with mu? I'm trying to
understand brother. You came at the
event. It's got nothing to do with Gaza.
Yes. If it was a frustration for that
would understand. It's nothing to do
with Gaza. M's speech was about Gaza and
Palestine. You came out and said enjoin
forbid. You don't forbid the evil and
worship other than Allah.
Okay. What's your point, Yaki? What's
your point? Men agrees with you. What is
your point, Aki? I'm trying to
understand. What is the point? What is
it that you're trying to say? I don't
understand. You're not telling us.
You're just saying they're watering the
religion. So, what if I don't class
myself die? Maybe you might class me. Is
that okay? I'm watering down the
religion. Okay. Where's your evidence?
Like Allah says,
if you among the truthful, bring your
evidence, bro. Tell us. What are we
watering down, bro? Please come and tell
us. Tell us what on what basis. Who you
talking about? Are you talking about
somebody else and you're taking out on
all of us? What is your point? I haven't
watched the full video. I don't know
what the brother's point is, but in a
nutshell, brothers and sisters, wi his
friend, I don't know if he was in it.
This brother looks mine. He looks mine.
His friend though using that lying is a
lie. And then promoting his green pill.
Brother, I'm I'm so sorry. We just want
a parent, bro. That's not a coincidence.
That's not a coincidence that you
automatically put green pill and then
subscribe and sign, etc. Fear Allah.
Your risk is from Allah. Don't go to
these little um uh plotting. You're
plotting against another believer. Allah
will humiliate you. That's why I've done
this video, bro. Today I'm I'm going
away. Yes, my family's waiting. I was so
annoyed when I saw this. Subhan Allah.
So, I can see the full video of what
this brother saying, but in a nutshell,
my brother, I don't know what the issue
is. I don't know. You've brought no
evidence to the table of why you've done
what you've done. You, if anything,
need to give apology to Mu. You need to
apologize. Your friend, if you was in on
this. Yes. It looks like it was a plot.
Yes. Your friend has to repent for
lying, misconstring. You, my friend,
brother. Yes. You seem like a good
brother. You're our brother. We love you
for the sake of Allah. We don't hate
you, brother. Please study your religion
and ad manners, bro. Please. The
prophetam said, I came for nothing but
to perfect good manners. Goodl good adab
with the people with Allah subhana wa
tala first. Yes. With his messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Yes. How
could you have goodl with the messenger
of Allah when the when Mu is talking and
quoting Allah and his messenger and you
interrupt him? What kind ofl and is this
bro? If someone's talking about Allah
and his messenger, how can I come and
stop the talk?
All I'm going to say is that cuz I don't
have the full video. You've put no
substance, no evidence, nothing. There's
someone watering the religion and we
need to enjoy good for evil. Yeah. Okay.
What you said is right. Okay. What's
your point? Nothing.
Bronx and sisters, do not forget to
donate to the Norway project for the new
masjid in we are trying to build.